[Musique]
nous sommes le 13 avril 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8 c
les invités aujourd'hui je reçois et
clémence algérie représentant de jacques
cheminade dans les yvelines nous ferons
le point sur ces derniers jours de
campagne c'est la troisième fois que son
candidat tente le pari de la
présidentielle solidarité et progrès
actuellement créditée d'un pour cent des
intentions de vote dans les enquêtes
d'opinion
à chaque été au mois de juillet au mois
d'août le conseil départemental recrute
150 étudiants qui rendent visite à des
personnes âgées isolées le dispositif
yvelines étudiants seniors est une
spécificité du département mise en place
donc à l'été 2004 nous en parlerons avec
marie hélène aubert c'est la
vice-présidente à l'autonomie à du
département des yvelines
bonsoir à tous les deux et bienvenue sur
ce plateau on va commencer par parler de
politique de la campagne de la
présidentielle avec vous que mons alger
représentants de jacques cheminade dans
les yvelines de ce mouvement solidarité
et progrès pourquoi ce soutien à jacques
cheminade candidat je le rappelle et qui
plafonne autour de 1% d'intentions de
vote mais je le soutiens parce que
l'huile depuis longtemps dénoncé la
folie financière qui s'est développée
dans l'économie en fait au début des
années 80 il a démissionné de son poste
de haut fonctionnaire pour se battre
contre cette spéculation et donc
quelqu'un qui a osé aller au bout de ses
idées puis dire qu'on doit remettre
l'argent en direction de l'économie de
l'infrastructure de la santé et c'est
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
pouvoir parler de choses comme ça mais
le fait qu'ils s'attaquer à la
spéculation à la finance ça m'a paru
crédible puisque sinon on pourra rien
faire et ça sera que des belles paroles
c'est sa troisième campagne pour vous
c'est la deuxième campagne vous l'avez
soutenu également en 2000
vous vous êtes toujours aussi motivé
même si justement les intentions de vote
peine à décoller oui je suis toujours
aussi motivé après les sondages sont pas
toujours fiables et puis aussi on
soutient on a des gens qui ont été très
médiatisées depuis longtemps donc ils
ont soutenu après le débat avec tous les
candidats on expliqué que jacques
cheminade n'avait pas forcément
convaincu mais nous c'est ça c'est pas
du tout ça qu'on a vu en rencontrant les
gens en militant des gens qui avaient
apprécié qu'il est attaqué le franc cfa
par exemple des gens qui avaient
apprécié qu'il avait l'air sincère on a
eu plutôt des bons retours dans con
évidemment il ya peu de chance de d'être
élu président de la république mais il
peut mettre des idées sur le débat
obligé à ce que certaines choses soient
soient discutées pour que le prochain
président soit tenu par ça donc je pense
qu'il peut vraiment faire quelque chose
en tout cas fait entendre ses idées vous
avez une trentaine d'années ce que vous
aviez déjà rejoint d'autres partis
politiques par le passé où c'est votre
premier engagement
non non je n'avais pas rejoindre
d'autres partis politiques avant j'ai
milité avec solidarité progrès comme le
premier parti le seul jacques cheminade
à 75 ans est le doyen des onze
prétendants à l'elysée est ce qu il
représente l'avenir
oui oui je pense que on a des gens qui
sont plus jeunes mais qui sont entrés
vieux dans leur tête et donc c'est
quelqu'un qui est jeune dans sa tête
donc je pense que ça vaut le coup de
voter pour lui j'appelle tous les gens à
voter pour lui puis s'ils veulent
vérifier s'il est jeune dans sa tête il
va faire un meeting de mardi prochain il
va faire concurrence aux débats ici
malheureusement réalisé sur votre
antenne mais donc j'invite les gens à
voir ils peuvent trouver sur sur
cheminade 2017 pourrait faire le lien
donc on va parler de quelques points du
programme juste auparavant pour vous
présenter aussi vous êtes engagés dans
cette campagne et pas uniquement en tant
que militant auprès de cette formation
politique vous avez été candidat aussi
par le passé sur des législatives
partielles sur toulouse oui voilà j'ai
été candidat sur toulouse donc je suis
un grand voyageur je vais là où là où il
ya besoin de moi et puis j'étais sur
toulouse
et puis hélas aujourd'hui me voilà ici
donc ça veut dire vous pourriez être
candidats pour les législatives sur le
secteur yvelinois c'est possible après
ce sera aussi en fonction de nos moyens
financiers parce que pour les
législatives ya pas le la même chose que
pour les présidentielles où il ya un
financement de tous les candidats qui
ont les 500 signatures quel que soit le
pourcentage
donc c'est au minimum six mille euros
pour faire campagne si on va voir
beaucoup de candidats ça fait beaucoup
d'argent mais en tout cas je compte
je compte lettre le slogan de campagne
de jacques cheminade éclair
libérons-nous de l'occupation financière
dans son programme il veut une france
qui redeviennent complètement
indépendante dans la gestion de ses
affaires concrètement ça va se passer
comment on quitte l'union européenne on
quitte l'euro s'est aussi parmi les
propositions
oui oui on sort de l'union européenne et
de l'euro mais il propose de revenir à
une monnaie commune mais pas unique et
puis que les états donc notamment la
france pour ce qui le concerne retrouve
contrôle sur sa monnaie qui puisse
emprunter à la banque de france comme
c'était le cas dans l'après guerre dans
les années 60 où on a fait des grands
projets aussi et donc c'est comme ça
qu'il pense pouvoir retrouver
l'indépendance de la france et que la
france aussi arêtes du coup d'être
suiveurs toujours de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis par exemple ce que ce soit
pour les guerres qui sont menées un peu
partout comme on a en ce moment en syrie
il était notamment au liban en fin de
semaine dernière où il a rencontré le
président à eaunes et où il a pu
discuter de ces choses là et où une
france indépendante
justement arrêterez de déstabiliser la
région c'est ce qu'il pense mais pas de
repli national pour autant voilà c'est
ça a pas de repli national pour nous
c'est pas du tout le sens de la chose
c'est au contraire un état indépendant
pour pouvoir justement main rayonner
dans le monde et travailler avec les
autres participer par exemple au projet
de nouvelle route de la soie que
proposent les chinois qui propose des
projets de coopération dans les
infrastructures qui proposent
aujourd'hui des programmes de
reconstruction d'ailleurs en syrie en
irak parce que les pays occidentaux ne
font généralement jamais de projets de
reconstruction il ya des pourparlers de
paix mais on discute pas de
reconstruction
donc je pense nous pensons qu'il faut
participer là-dedans quoique il faut pas
laisser aller les autres il faut
participer à cette histoire qui change
est ce que jacques cheminade vais
toujours coloniser la lune et mars parce
que ça fait toujours partie de son
programme
en fait aujourd'hui par exemple vous
avez jean luc mélenchon qui a un
programme spatial il faut envoyer des
robots sur mars et ailleurs mais on
n'entend personne ont trouvé ça bizarre
parce qu'il ya cette image je vous pose
cette question absolument pas ce qui
colle deux candidats voilà de lunettes
mais aura-t-il sera jacques cheminade
oui oui tout à fait sauf qu'en réalité
bon la france de toute manière est la
première puissance spatiale européenne
ça n'a rien de ça serait même étonnant
de ne pas parler de du spatial en fait
quand on est en france et c'est ça qui
se passe pour certains c'est donc voilà
le spatial comme beaucoup d'autres
choses et tout simplement un facteur
important dans lequel nous pensons qu'il
faut investir il faut être à la pointe
de la recherche dans tous les domaines
notamment dans le spatial il reste une
dizaine de jours de campagne dernière
question comment ça va s'organiser pour
vous sur le terrain dans les yvelines
concrètement il y aura des distributions
de tracts des réunions oui voilà des
distributions de tracts des rencontres
dans des cafés du porte-à-porte voilà on
va continuer à les discuter à les
convaincre et les dire aux gens voter
cheminade et vous serez pouvait remettre
une épée dans deux du prochain président
pour le pousser à faire ce qu'il faut et
vous serez présent vous aussi comme les
autres représentants yvelinois des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
sur ce plateau pour le débat qui sera
diffusée sur cette antenne mardi
prochain mardi 18 avril à partir de 21h
merci à vous que les montages et
présentant de jacques cheminade dans les
yvelines
chaque été depuis à 2004 le conseil
départemental avec les centres communaux
d'action sociale recrute 150 étudiants
pour rendre visite à des personnes âgées
isolées durant les mois de juillet des
mois d'août un dispositif original qui
permet des échanges entre générations et
puis un enrichissement personnel bien
évidemment bonsoir à vous vous êtes
conseillère départementale des yvelines
vice-présidente à l'autonomie depuis la
mise en place de yes puisque c'est le
nom de ce dispositif il dispositif
yvelines étudiants seniors
près de mille cinq cent cinquante
étudiants recrutés pour des emplois
saisonniers
plus de 96 mille visites
lisez ça sert à quoi tout ça quel bilan
vous en faites depuis 2004 et eu un vrai
échange est quelque chose qui est né de
cette opération
bien sûr ça empreinte remporté un grand
succès parce que ça répond à des besoins
d'avoir ça répond aux besoins des
personnes âgées parce que vous savez que
l'été quand les voisins et la famille
quand tout le monde dans le quartier
partie on se retrouve seul qu'on est une
personne âgée un peu dépendantes
c'est très difficile donc la visite de
ces étudiants qui apporte un peu de
jeunesse et de vie c'est très très
apprécié ça nous permet aussi d'avoir un
oeil pour savoir que tout se passe bien
chez la personne et que si vous savez ce
dispositif a été mis en place en après
2003 après la canicule de 2003 on s'est
rendu compte que la canicule quand on
est isolé c'est un grand danger
donc là on lutte contre les zones mal
apprécié ce que c'est gratuit aussi pour
les seniors
mais c'est un investissement pour le
conseil départemental plus de 400000
euros sur sept cette opération les
seniors qui veulent en bénéficier
doivent se manifester auprès du conseil
départemental où c'est automatique
comment ça fonctionnait les seniors se
manifestent auprès leur ccas qui le csv
remonter ces informations auprès du pôle
autonomie du territoire et est ensuite
ses prix en char s'organiser pour que
les étudiants et une petite liste de
personnes à visiter pendant l'été et
s'organise en fonction de ça aujourd'hui
le nombre de seniors est en hausse dans
le département des yvelines
mais insiste un vieillissement de la
population bien sûr aussi bien sûr bien
sûr on est un des départements qui un
vieillissement le plus rapide
on y vieillit bien globalement
un département qui prend le plus soin de
ses seniors et ce dispositif d'ailleurs
est enviée et jalousé par nombre de
départements
ailleurs c'est il nous coûte très cher
mais rend tellement de services à la
fois aux étudiants parce que quand on
est étudiant et qu'on cherche un job
d'été qu'on est payé au smic sur la base
de 35 heures et puis que c'est quand
même plus gratifiant de d'aller voir des
personnes âgées de se sentir un petit
peu distributeur de bonheur et plutôt
que de servir des frites sans vouloir
être péjoratif
on peut distribuer des voix du bonheur
aux sarments d'affilée aussi mais si on
peut aider les seniors c'est quand même
effectivement avec une visée un peu plus
sociale et humaine plus importante c'est
sur rémunérés vous l'avais dit au niveau
du smic sur une base de 35 heures il ya
un recrutement qui s'opère donc là en ce
moment les jeunes vous envoie des cv et
postule et postule en ligne sur le site
du conseil départemental et à pièces
pour assurer sur la passagère
effectivement et et puis et puis on leur
demande leur pedigree en gros il faut
qu'ils aient un an de permis de conduire
parce que bien sûr il faut que ça
déplace d'une personne à l'autre en
étant autonome et puis qu'ils soient
yvelinois bien sûr voilà et ensuite ils
vont comment ça fonctionne concrètement
ils ont misé ou le disiez il rencontre
plusieurs peu de personnes âgées tout au
long de la journée et voilà il ya pas
des deux médical qui est à portée
uniquement du lien voilà surtout pas
surtout pas en laisse aux professionnels
ce qui relève du dessous un
professionnel et puis eux ils sont là
pour la convivialité pour tenir
compagnie pour changer les idées pour
voilà pour être bien pour apporter du
bonheur pour jouer aux cartes pour aller
faire des courses pour aller chez le
coiffeur
voilà pour pour faire se rencontrer
aussi le voisin qui ne connaissait pas
ça arrive il ya une journée de formation
en néanmoins pour les jeunes qui veulent
postuler qui s'inquiète aussi d'être
lâchés comme ça il ya une journée de
formation de préalables formation
préalable d'une journée qui est organisé
par le conseil départemental
au-delà de cette opération qui se
déroule sur les mois de juillet et les
mois d'août est ce qu'on peut imaginer
que ça se prolonge tout au long de
l'année il ya eu une expérience il
semble dans le département en 2015 2015
2016 dont la
à tester on a persévéré pendant deux ans
sur le mantois avec quatre villes qui
étaient quatre communes qui était
volontaire c'était un petit peu
compliqué de le faire toute l'année on
va faire un bilan on va voir ce qu'il
est possible d'améliorer j'aimerais
vraiment beaucoup que ça se poursuive
toute l'année parce que ça rend vraiment
vraiment service isolement c'est le
principal frein la principale difficulté
pour le maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées donc il faut vraiment
qu'on agisse encore davantage quand vous
êtes un peu compliqué c'est
financièrement aussi c'est compliqué ce
qu'on se débrouille toujours pour ça
mais enfin on essaye mais c'est aussi
pour trouver les personnes qui sont
volontaires toute l'année les dents les
jeunes parce que les étudiants et
s'occuper dans l'année d'un comme il
faut l'idéal c'est d'avoir effectivement
un référent les services alicante être
non voilà mais c'est pour ça que je
travaille la chose se remettre en place
malgré ça est-ce que les liens qui se
sont créés pendant l'été vous constatez
que les jeunes continuent à échanger
avec les personnes âgées et qu'ils
viennent pas juste là pendant deux mois
un mois et s'en vont après vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer les liens qui se
créent
c'est extraordinaire c'est magnifique
c'est des gens qui au départ des
personnes âgées qui était un petit peu
réticent vous savez ouvrir sa porte
c'est toujours chez les personnes âgées
je n'oserais pas compliqué et puis
finalement il ya des liens magnifique
qui se créent et j'ai des témoignages
absolument ravissant et adorable de
personnes âgées qui qui qui gardent le
contact et ça crée des vocations chez
les jeunes
ma directrice du ccs gelé recruter suite
à l été cette ampleur jeunes et
j'ai délirante jeanne avoir posté sur
cette opération s yvelines étudiant
senior vous l'avez compris c'est une
belle opération en plus pour les jeunes
vous êtes rémunérés pour les seniors
c'est gratuit ça permet de créer du lien
durant l'été peut-être plus tard tout au
long de l'année
si l'expérience venait à être pérennisée
sur l'ensemble des douze mois merci
d'être venu nous en parler aujourd'hui
en plateau yvelines point fr slash yes
pour pouvoir postuler vous inscrire
envoyez vos cv en ligne c'est la fin de
ce set 8 les invités replay sur notre
site internet et puis également à
consulter sur notre application mobile à
très bientôt
[Musique]